it's one of the most fondly remembered
and easily re-watchable movies of all
time so tear open a baby root then Never
say die as you uncover some things you
may not have known about The Goonies
just before filming was scheduled to
begin Jeff Cohen who played Chunk came
down with a nasty case at the chickenpox
he reported to set anyway fully ready to
work fearing that if you delayed the
production with the sickness the
director would just recast his role
Cohen kept the pox hidden until he had
to lift up his shirt to do the Truffle
Shuffle for the first time which
revealed The Telltale spots come on
do it
Cohen's Health improved but he still had
a hard time on set he was self-conscious
about his weight made worse because his
character was almost always eating Cohen
particularly lamented chunks whipped
cream scene
[Music]
I impressed
actor estimates that he had to do 50
takes of the bit which meant 50
mouthfuls of cream J Michael Riva served
as the production designer on the film
The Prop Department had lovingly crafted
the movie's vitally important pirate
treasure map but Riva thought that it
looked too new since the movie was
shooting on location in Oregon he was
limited in terms of the materials he had
on hand to age the paper so he started
by dumping coffee on it that made it
look old but he still thought it wasn't
authentic enough it was missing
something that would make it truly look
like a pirate's treasure map blood the
prop Squad didn't have any shades of red
he liked so Reba literally took matters
into his own hands he told NPR we
actually had to cut our fingers and Edge
the sides of it with blood you do these
crazy things you get so into it the
pirate ship that looms large in The
Goonies is called The Inferno as big as
a real seaworthy vessel it was modeled
after the ship in the classic Errol
Flynn swashbuckler the Seahawk The
Inferno was more than a hundred feet
long with sails made up of more than
seven thousand square feet of fabric
some of the riggans were recycled from
Disneyland's Pirates of the Caribbean
ride which was being remodeled at the
time The Goonies was in production it
took two and a half months to construct
The Inferno so the hype about what it
would look like was a feverish
discussion topic on set director Richard
Donner made sure that none of the main
casts saw the ship until the exact
moment their characters did he wanted
the reactions of excitement and all he
filmed to be genuine
oh my God
blade brand was indeed impressed when he
saw The Inferno for the first time he
broke character and swore the take was
ruined and another not quite authentic
reaction shot was filmed before licensed
to drive the Lost Boys Dream a Little
Dream and the reality show the two
quarries Teen Idols Corey Haim and Corey
Feldman were just individual quarries
going about their business as child
actors in Hollywood they were often up
for the same roles in the same movie
such as The Goonies the two quarries
actually met each other for the first
time in the waiting room of Steven
Spielberg's amblin entertainment the
company producing the movie both
quarries were up for the part of mouth
Feldman of course got the parts while
Hayne did not but at least he made a
friend and landed him his own
breakthrough role at about the same time
The Goonies has a little something for
everyone adventure action comedy and
even some innocent romantic moments the
script called for a kiss between older
teen Andy played by Carrie green and
Sean aston's Young Mikey in reality
green was also older than Aston by a
difference of about four years she
dreaded the kiss not because there was
any anything wrong with Aston but
because as an 18 year old adult woman
appearing in her first movie no less she
felt creepy having to kiss a 13 year old
boy she jokingly likened it to a
criminal offense to 17 and said the two
of us were so scared it wasn't much
easier for green to film her kissing
scene with a more age-appropriate Josh
Brolin either the actress later told
people it's the time of your life when
you are the most self-conscious anyway
and you're being filmed and you have to
kiss Josh Brolin just humiliating today
re-experiencing a favorite film is easy
all you have to do is wait a few months
and you can watch the DVD or stream it
to your heart's content Goonies Never
Say Die
foreign
not so for the early VHS era in the mid
80s when The Goonies was released a VHS
copy of a movie could be expensive on
the other hand novelizations were cheap
novelizations were once a major part of
a movie's promotional Arsenal but to
make sure they were on shelves when a
movie was in theaters novelizations were
written when the movies were still in
production novelization writers often
wrote from an early version of a
screenplay before scenes are cut out of
the finished movie entirely in the
novelization of The Goonies there are
some big extras that didn't quite make
it to the screen particularly a lengthy
epilogue in the book it's revealed that
Chuck's family adopts sloth they even
throw him a bar mitzvah sure there was
never an official big screen sequel to
The Goonies but the film is part of a
broader Cinematic Universe there's no
GCU or anything like that but a quick
comic scene in the movie connects The
Goonies to the Gremlins franchise when
chunk is trapped with Sloth in The
patelli's Hideaway he finds a way to
call the police these authorities are of
little help to Port chunk just like that
last prank about all those little
creatures that multiply like when you
throw water on them those Critters are
of course the Mogwai from Gremlins which
multiply if they get wet Gremlins like
The Goonies was a Steven Spielberg
production and Chris Columbus wrote the
screenplays for both movies complicating
matters is how Corey Feldman appeared in
both as well before portraying a goonie
named mouth he was Pete the first person
who spilled water on a Mogwai in
Gremlins check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]